[Musique]
bon j'en ai reprend voilà le temps
d'égaliser le niveau de mon casque et et
nous y sommes bonjour 10 me bonjour à
toutes et à tous bonjour béatrice bellay
bonjour bonjour à toutes les auditrices
et tous les auditeurs de martinique la
première c'est une première secrétaire
de la fédération socialiste de la
martinique est membre du bureau national
du parti socialiste tout à fait
secrétaire national à l'égalité réelle
voilà alors on va en parler justement de
l'égalité réelle ah vous êtes là bien
sûr en soutien de la candidate anne
hidalgo on y va tout de suite béatrice
bellay à deux semaines du scrutin qu'est
ce qui vous motive encore vous
personnellement mais bon toute l'équipe
qui lie à autour d'anne hidalgo alors
que la plupart des sondages semblent
montrer que la campagne électorale de la
candidate présentée par le ps n'arrive
pas à décoller écoutez moi je crois que
ce qu'il doit nous motiver au delà tout
dans une élection c'est le fait de
porter des idées le fait de porter aussi
et c'est singulièrement important pour
cette élection de porter un idéal de vie
et de porter l'idée que l'on se fait de
ce que doit être la france la france
doit être une terre de solidarité la
france n'a pas d'autre choix que de
redevenir sociale nous l'avons vu nous
le voyons dans les temps de crise c'est
cette solidarité cette vision et 7 ce
modèle que l'on peut avoir pour le monde
qui va déterminer notre notre réalité
quotidienne et jeudi au martiniquaise
aux martiniquais écouter lisez les
programmes ne vous laissez pas avoir
justement par des sondages qui
maintenant sont des sondages payés sont
même plus des sondages avec des
personnes qui sont choisis dans un
palais l'eau au hasard mais des
personnes qui s'inscrivent qui sont
payés pour faire des sondages et dont
pour la plupart du temps les patrons de
ces grandes agences de sondage sont
aussi des patrons des médias qui met en
avant l'extrême droite et la droite
aujourd'hui au pouvoir donc soyez très
vigilants je ne comprends pas moi
comment un président qui annonce que la
retraite va être à 65 ans peut se
retrouver dès le lendemain à 30
30% d'intentions de vote donc je crois
que il ya une espèce de fabrique de
l'opinion est divisée je pense qu on a
pu voir la fabrique de l'opinion d'un
des candidats qui sont ou ont été
fabriqués par les médias et j'entends
par là par exemple eric zemmour à qui on
a laissé une plaine possibilité de
déverser ces ignominies pendant près de
deux ans sur un média privé et sa
facilité évidemment aujourd'hui
l'étendue et de sa personne et sa
visibilité néanmoins cette élection
continue de se présenter avec une gauche
fracturée tout à fait et c'est très
dommage et j'en suis la première désolé
moi j'aurais aimé qu'il y ait eu parce
que la gauche n'a toujours gagné elle
n'a toujours gagné que rassembler c'est
une réalité n'a toujours gagné leur
assemblée donc fracturée et séparés
comme elle l'est nous nous aurons et
nous allons tous vers des difficultés
même si certains s'en sortent toujours
dans ces sondages mieux que d'autres
mais en tout cas la gauche n'a gagné que
lorsqu'elles étaient rassemblés donc
vous gardez un certain espoir je garde
un espoir il y aura un deuxième tour je
garde aussi l'espoir que dans ce
deuxième temps qui est ce lui aussi des
élections législatives chacun réalise qu
il faut donner les moyens à la
population de voir voter des lois qui
vont venir modifier leur quotidien dans
le bon sens et pas dans l'aggravation
des situations de précarité notamment de
ce point de vue quel regard portez-vous
justement sur le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron et son équipe alors concernant
plus particulièrement la great war
d'outre-mer était le nôtre et sur les
territoires d'outre-mer le bilan est
clair plus de précarité plus de
difficultés des entreprises en
difficulté ca c c'est quelque chose de
clair plus aussi de départ des services
publics qui ont eu tendance à diminuer
en termes d'efficacité
une précarité évidemment que l'on sait
plus grande puisqu'il ya une réforme de
l'assurance chômage monsieur macro ayant
considéré que les chômeurs étaient
fautifs lorsqu'il n'ya pas d'emploi on
n'a pas d'autre choix que de bénéficier
de la solidarité est bien souvent
évidemment contrairement à ce qu'il veut
faire croire les personnes qui sont
chômage rêverait de retrouver un emploi
donc c'est une cassure également de ce
lien social que les dispositions la
manière de laquelle monsieur macro à
gouverner ces cinq dernières années à
opposer les français les uns aux autres
et à une tendance également opposé les
martiniquais les uns aux autres et là je
parle de la situation sanitaire où nous
nous sommes tous retrouvés confrontés
non pas à des ânes ou même au final mais
mais à des décisions que nous devions
jugé pour lesquelles nous devions
prendre des décisions pour nous mêmes et
qui nous mettant en confrontation avec
les autres donc je crois que monsieur
macron aujourd'hui ce qu'il promet c'est
un monde et une france dans laquelle les
plus précaires seront encore précarisés
je rappelle monsieur macron 5 euros -
d'apn des étudiants avec des bourses qui
est qui promet d'ailleurs un dans le pr
pour son prochain quinquennat des études
payantes qui promet la retraite à 65 ans
donc voilà le monde que monsieur macron
propose et j'espère que les martiniquais
seront le moins les moins nombreux
possible à a participé de d'une
éventuelle victoire c'est ce qui fait
dire donc à anne hidalgo que je la cite
la république avait oublié l'égalité
réelle pour les outre-mer alors vous
êtes secrétaire national à l'égalité
elle a tellement oublier que je vous
rappelle qu'en 2017 le parti socialiste
et le gouvernement socialiste a voté
enfin il l'assemblée a voté ont voté une
loi égalité réelle pour l'outre-mer qui
faisait quoi j'ai entendu monsieur
macron sur la chaîne publique dire que à
ce saint cannat là il va s'occuper quand
même un peu d'égalité mais la vie noah
il avait une loi qu avait été votée en
2017 et qu'il n'a pas souhaité appliquer
qui avait dès qu'ils mettent en place
des instruments pour réduire cette
influence des monopoles qui fait que nos
prix sont aujourd'hui exagérer on le
voit tout le monde le voit moins les
mots kalimat faire en plein l'essence
manque a tout fait lorsque je vais faire
mes courses et que je me rends compte
que j'en ai pour 150 euros et que je
n'ai qu'à un cabas qui tient sous mon
bras manquent a tout fait aussi est la
question que je me pose alors que moi je
suis salarié que je travaille c'est
comment font ceux qui ont moins que moi
voilà donc aujourd'hui il y à une loi
égalité réelle que monsieur macron a
fait le choix de ne pas appeler kay et
qui pourtant sur beaucoup de volets sur
celui et je rappelle que c'est des
socialistes qui ont fait en sorte que la
baisse du sucre dans nos aliments la
baisse la visibilité que nous avons
cherché à connaître sur la constitution
des prix parce qu'au-delà de l'octroi de
mer dont on parle il y a aussi des
marges qui se fond qui se font avec des
gens de la grande distribution qui se
partagent un gâteau et qui ne jouent pas
toujours le jeu donc cela ne l'avait pas
attaquer les vrais nabeul 1 matagne de
tous et non il ne les actionnaires et du
tout la preuve vous le voyez comme moi
même les prix et ce n'est pas seulement
depuis l'ukraine les prix ont augmenté
en martinique nous sommes passés de 22 %
de différence de prix entre l'hexagone
et la martinique à 38% s'est confirmée
dans les dernières chier dans les
derniers chiffres de l'insee
alors selon les socialistes toujours
donc qu'il faudrait alors ça fait partie
des priorités des mesures annoncées
pallier les défaillances des services
publics chez nous et le manque
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures
cela fera l'objet d'un plan de
rattrapage mais est ce qu'on peut avoir
un ou deux exemples de la façon dont ça
pourrait se décliner si jamais anne
hidalgo la paix a buté dont parle anne
hidalgo c'est la réalité que nous voyons
tous les jours sur des services qui sont
des services essentiels celui de l'eau
l'état aujourd'hui ne peut pas dire vous
avez entendu aussi monsieur macron c'est
celui qui paye qui décide bon mais c'est
pas comme ça celui qui paye aurait dû
payer bien avant en martinique lorsque
l'état décidé de se désengager sur l'eau
il avait déjà structuré de façon
très parfaite quasi-parfaite ses réseaux
en france hexagonale nous lorsque l'état
décidé de se désengager nos réseaux
étaient en train d'être construit ce qui
veut dire que les villes à l'époque se
sont retrouvés avec des charges pour
monter des réseaux qui n'était pas
soutenable pour ce qu'elle était en
martinique le la candidat socialiste dit
nous devons rattraper ce que nous
n'avons pas fait ce que nous n'avons pas
fait ces cinquante dernières années et
donc nous mettrons les moyens à
disposition des collectivités pour
qu'elles puissent engager les travaux et
en l'occurrence par exemple sur l'eau
ces 350 millions d'euros qu'il faut
l'état doit pouvoir venir mettre sa part
les collectivités vont mettre leur parle
évidemment mais l'europe pourra
également si l'état s'engage les europe
pourra s'engager s'ils le l'état ne
s'engage pas l'europe ne s'engagera pas
c'est le principe des cofinancements
aujourd'hui donc ce plan de rattrapage y
tient aussi sur l'éducation nous voyons
que sur l'éducation il y a des choses à
rattraper nous avons des décrochages
scolaires qui sont importants nous avons
aussi un système qui ne produit pas
obligatoirement la réussite que nous
pouvons en attendre donc il faut
structurer notamment de l'école
maternelle à l'école primaire c'est
d'état qui à cette charge et nous devons
également dans les études supérieures
structuré et prendre conscience oui nous
ne pouvons pas avoir les mêmes choses
que l'hexagone nous ne pouvons pas tout
avoir mais ce que nous avons comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui avec ce deuxième
cycle de médecine ce que nous avons nous
devons essayer de l'avoir de façon
complète alors il nous reste une minute
on a parlé j'ai parlé
quelques mois et je parle évidemment en
terme de rattrapage de la santé il faut
que nous notre accès aux soins pas
simplement avec les chu mais avec des
maisons santé avec une répartition avec
aussi un programme d'incitations pour
des spécialistes pour aller sur des
zones qui sont appelés des déserts
médicaux nous avons dans ce plan de
rattrapage également ces mesures qui
vont pouvoir être mises en place avec la
candidate anne hidalgo en quelques
secondes un peu de politique fiction si
jamais un second tour opposait emmanuel
macron à jean luc mélenchon par exemple
vous appelleriez au ps et vous
personnellement à voter pour qui
j'appellerais très clairement moins à
voter à gauche et donc à voter jean luc
mélenchon voilà c'est répondu clairement
merci béatrice bel et vous restez avec
nous pour les questions des auditrices
et des auditeurs à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
oui ces questions on sait maintenant qui
fait qu'il faut les poser en nous
appelant 05
83 on va juste avoir un petit point sur
l'actualité nationale et internationale
et on posera vous pourrez poser ces
questions à bbb en direct à la radio
donc n'hésitez surtout pas